[Music]
the fallout from Caitlyn Jenner's memoir
continues everything she says is all
made up my book is honest and it's my
story in the secrets of my life
Caitlyn calls ex Kris Jenner controlling
and says she was against her transition
while Kris claims she was not aware of
Caitlyn's gender identity struggle
during their marriage but the former
Olympian tells Andy Cohen a different
story I had been on hormones for four
and a half years leading up to that
point when I met her uh yeah it was very
noticeable but I was honest
did I downplay it I'm sure I did but I
was honest with her Caitlyn omits they
had 23 great years together but does she
think Kris overreacted to the book that
really ticked me off because that
separates me from my children
my heart breaks from my mom it appears
lines have been drawn between the family
Caitlyn says she has to spoken to Khloe
in two years she doesn't wanna talk to
me either you know that's sad not having
you in my life it says she would blow
ask for her time on Keeping Up with the
Kardashians Caitlyn tells Andi she
wasn't paid a dime